[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sachez que nous sommes tous en train
d'expérimenter le vieillissement vous
moi nous nous sommes des praticiens du
vieillissement
certains sont juste plus expérimentés
que d'autres et nous pouvons nous
appuyer sur leur expérience pour choisir
quel individu on veut devenir pour
choisir nos rides pour choisir nos
cheveux blancs et pour expérimenter nos
vulnérabilités
moi je suis tombé dans le vieillissement
quand j'étais petite ma grand mère ne
m'a pas appris à vieillir
elle m'a appris à vivre mais mais
c'était une capsule de fraîcheur une
coquetterie dans les boucles des ses
cheveux blancs un soupçon de baisers
volés sur ses joues fripé et les marques
de la poussière du temps sur ses mains
mais mais m'a transmis sa finesse sa
gaieté et la détermination de faire des
choix peut accepter par son époque
ma grand mère décédée quand j'avais 8
ans vivaient dans la même rue que nous
ma mère et moi et faisait partie de mon
quotidien
à mon tour j'ai décidé de garder cette
proximité géographique et de vivre à 20
minutes de chez ma mère prenons quelques
instants pour parler de vous
demandez-vous quel parent de vous même
dans vos comportements dans votre
physique ressemble à vos grands parents
souvenez-vous de leurs tics de langage
de leur style vestimentaire de leur
odeur de leurs paroles ou d'histoire
invraisemblable
avez vous trouvé peut-être que c'est
aussi des personnalités qui ont marqué
votre expérience du vieillissement
lily tomlin ou jane fonda
dans grèce et francky qui crée à plus de
70 ans une entreprise
ken loach qui continue de faire des
films à plus de 80 ans ou peut-être
nelson mandela qui a 76 ans est devenu
président d'afrique du sud
alors je vous parle de ces personnalités
parce qu'elles ont toutes un point en
commun avec ma grand mère vous en doutez
eh bien ce sont des artistes les
artistes ce sont des créateurs de
manière de vivre qui cultivent
constamment leurs différences ils
explorent le changement ils nous
inspirent et ils façonnent de nouveaux
modèles que ce soit ken loach
quand il crée ses films et qu'il parle
des inégalités sociales que ce soit
aussi jane fonda
quand elle soutient les droits civiques
ou ma grand mère quand elle fait le
choix de divorcer en 1958
ce sont des artistes ce sont nos
artistes et je suis certaine aussi que
dans votre entourage vous en avez des
artistes alors comme l'a écrit simone de
beauvoir brison la conspiration du
silence et sortons du regard négatif que
l'on porte sur le vieillissement en
france en février 2018 le comité
consultatif national d'éthique qui a
pour mission à la fois de donner des
avis sur des questions éthiques et de
société a souligné que la société
française était hagist impulser une peur
de vieillir et isoler les plus âgés dans
une société de la performance de
l'urgence et du jeunisme est ce que vous
vous avez envie sous prétexte que vous
avez 60 ans 70 ans ou plus d'être mis de
côté rejeté par la société
mais comment en sommes nous arrivés à
vivre dans une société hagist
et bien pour cela je vous propose de
faire un voyage dans le temps dans
l'imaginaire collectif
on a aussi y est en train ailleurs
acquis en attribuer des valeurs
d'autorité de respect et de sagesse et à
côte c'est ça on avait le vieux
misérable miséreux et fragile quand on
évoquait le sujet des femmes elles
étaient très souvent perçus en tant que
sorcières suite aux révolutions
industrielles et numériques et à la mise
en place de politiques publiques
les plus âgés ont été ôtés de leurs
rôles sociaux comme le fait de tenir la
mémoire collectif mais aussi ils ont été
peu à peu
jugée inutile et improductif dans une
société où une personne sur trois aura
plus de 60 ans en france et une personne
sur six dans le monde en 2050 près d'un
tiers de l'humanité aura peu plus de 60
ans et j'en ferai partie je vous parle
de ce sujet du vieillissement parce que
cela fait onze ans que je travaille
dessus
je suis sociologue alors qu'angers
étudie les comportements les désirs les
besoins les attentes des plus âgés cela
me permet de comprendre les réalités
d'aujourd'hui mais cela me permet aussi
de le comprendre
demain notre demain et de pouvoir enfin
créer d'autres possibles à partir de ces
analyses je vais me permettre de vous
proposer une manière d'utiliser ce temps
qui passe une sorte de principe de
l'alchimie du temps pour explorer notre
expérience du vieillissement
alors en 2030 ce sera le temps des liens
sociaux
le temps de la participation sociale et
le temps de l'enthousiasmé bienveillant
3,2 millions de personnes de plus de 60
ans sont en risque d'isolement relations
elle c'est à dire n'ont aucun contact
par jour pas de téléphone qui sonne en
france en 2015 c'est à peu près 28 % des
plus de 65 ans qui sans qu'ils se
suicident sur l'ensemble des suicidants
c'est-à-dire 3000 sur 10000 et dans les
récentes statistiques de la santé
publique sur le sentiment et les
craintes liées au suicide et bien on
oublie les 75 ans dans ces statistiques
nous ne pouvons pas laisser faire ça en
2030 on vieillira entouré de gens qui
nous ressemblent on comptera sur des
gens dans nos quartiers dans nos
communes dans notre société on pourra
créer des lieux ouverts des lieux
ouverts tels que les tiers lieux des
conciergeries des espaces territoriaux
d'entre aide mais on pourra aussi
s'appuyer sur nos tribus nos tribus qui
nous ressemblent comme celle que j'ai
quand je vais faire du sport une tribu
qui soutient qui est présente qui
encouragent et qui peut même vous aider
à refaire la cuisine de votre parent âgé
prenons le deuxième temps celui de la
participation sociale
lors d'une étude que j'ai menées sur les
modes de vie des jeunes retraités j'ai
rencontré michel michel m'a dit depuis
que je suis à la retraite c'est un vide
c'est effroyable un véritable gouffre je
me sens inutile inutile ce qu'a ressenti
michel c'est ce que ressentent un
certain nombre de retraités quand ils
arrivent à la retraite qui n'est pas du
tout se retirer du monde mais qui peut
en donner ce sentiment
nous ne pouvons pas laisser faire ça
alors en 2030 est bien le mot retraite
n'existera plus
ces individus seront toujours comme
aujourd'hui des citoyens des auteurs des
acteurs et on valorisera l'engagement
l'implication pourquoi pas à travers d
économie circulaire des banques
d'activité où on pourra mettre en lien à
la fois les besoins
des territoires et les compétences des
individus
reprenons michel michel qui a des
compétences en jardinage très bon
jardinier il pourrait très bien aider
l'école du quartier qui vient tout juste
d'intégrer un potager dans sa cour le
troisième temps celui de l' enthousiasme
bienveillant vivre vieillir c'est aussi
pouvoir avancer vers le grand âge et
bien quand on arrive à ce moment-là de
la vie on a besoin d'être entouré par
des professionnels qui développe cet
enthousiasme bienveillant mais nous
sommes véritablement loin de la réalité
17 minutes par jour par personne sont
consacrés en ehpad à la toilette
il en faudrait 30 cette situation peut
entraîner de la maltraitance
involontaire en ehpad
mais aussi à domicile 75% des
maltraitances ont lieu à domicile et ont
lieu le plus souvent auprès de femmes
nous ne pouvons pas laisser faire ça en
nous aurons des professionnels qui
développeront cet enthousiasme
bienveillant à travers des modèles comme
monter souris ou humanitude ses modèles
valorise à la fois la présence
l'écoutent la dignité la singularité la
prise en compte de la personne de la
personne âgée
bien évidemment pour cela il faut des
moyens
du temps des professionnels compétents
et revaloriser les métiers mais nous
vous moi nous que pouvons-nous faire au
quotidien pour devenir un vieux un peu
mieux chaque jour
je vais reprendre ces trois temps sur le
premier celui des liens sociaux
soyons des individus sur lesquels nos
artistes de la vie peuvent compter pour
équilibrer à la fois humaniste
et technologies revenons sur michel qui
vient tout juste d'installer une
application sportive pour comptabiliser
ces kilomètres
et puis eux surtout bénéficié d'une
communauté virtuelle
lorsque michel nous contactera pour
aller marcher avec lui et bien
acceptons et encourageons nous
mutuellement pas sont des moments en
commun avec lui et surtout veillons à ce
que nous ayons des liens sociaux avec
des âges différents
je vous parlais de la participation
sociale tout à l'heure et bien donnons
donnons faisons des choses sans rien
attendre en retour dans nos quartiers
dans nos immeubles dans nos communes
dans notre société
enfin l' enthousiasme bienveillant et
bien que vous soyez artistes de la vie
ou artistes débutants et bien soyez bien
évidemment enthousiaste riom chanteront
marchon mangeons du chocolat vibrons
soyons bienveillant prenons soin de nous
prenons soin des autres prenons soin de
la société essayons et jetons tombons
relevant nous pour enfin écrire nos
peintures la ville ce temps qui passe
c'est un peu comme une sorte
d'exposition
cette exposition n'est pas permanente
elle est en configuration perpétuelle
alors aujourd'hui sur mes étagères
j'aimerais y mettre des livres par
milliers des gants de boxe mais aussi
une photo de maman et de moi maman 75
ans mon artiste de la vie demain quand
je serai vieille j'aimerais trouver sur
mon étagère une boucle de mes cheveux
blancs des livres sur lesquels mon nom
sera inscrit mais aussi une photo de mes
petits enfants et de ma tribu peut-être
de mai tribu
jouons dans un potager dans lesquels on
en rappelant t d arbres des herbes
médicinales et on aura créé des actes
éco responsable j'aimerais aussi trouvé
sur ses étagères des valorisations
d'action politique et humaine que
j'aurais mis en place mené en
collaboration pour améliorer nos
conditions de vie et surtout celle des
femmes âgées alors pour finir j'aimerais
que vous releviez deux défis
le premier celui de devenir un vieux un
peu mieux chaque jour et le second de
regarder autour de vous et d'aller
échanger avec quelqu'un d'une autre
génération
[Applaudissements]